Fox News Alert President Trump is
tweeting that Nick Mulvaney who is his
OMB director in the head of the CFPB
will serve as his acting chief of staff
so not a permanent chief of staff but
Mick Mulvaney who I think man you might
know of he was a congressman from South
Carolina one your thoughts about Mick
Mulvaney taking over just to see them
through well I mean the big news before
this Dana was that Chris Christie the
former governor of New Jersey said he
was taking himself out and we've seen a
series of people say no I'm not going to
do it's a difficult job and it looks
like the coming two years are gonna be
turbulent I think a lot of people moved
away so Mick Mulvaney is really taking
one on now he has three jobs Jesse yeah
I mean Trump's chief of staff my mother
recommend that I not do that so now like
Christie I will be taking myself out of
consideration for a job Jesse
like I said before I think it's all
about personal chemistry with the
president and looks like has a nice
relationship and he could steer the
course in the next I don't know how long
it's gonna take to get a permanent one
maybe two weeks a month but I don't
think of a lot of the people's names
that were being bandied about like chris
Christie and David bossy were actually
in serious consideration and now the
president gets to go into the weekend
with a little bit of news that's a that
one that story we're gonna take it off
the page for this yeah I guess I I'm not
interested in in staffing changes as
much as I guess I'm supposed to be I
just see people go in and go out
Washington parler exactly I really
watching Sutton up people I won't
mention Santorum they were up and then
they're not up it's just like voting
their names loading their names I mean I
eat you know come on
um just to point out for viewers that
the the limit on acting on the role of
an acting position there's limits to
that but when the fact that the
President appointed him or nominated him
or whatever that that's that but in the
chief of staff role you could be acting
for a long time exactly and so that's it
makes it indefinite so it could be like
it could be a week in a month it could
be longer than that
Nalini had said that he was not
interested in that position that he
would like the job likes the jobs that
he has or would even consider a cabinet
position but the chief of staff role is
a good well I think he'd make a good
chief of staff and maybe he'll get in
there and decide that it's pretty good
you know that you're the gatekeeper for
the president the most interesting
possibility had been Jared Kushner that
if he had brought in Jared because
remember what happened was that the
previous chief of staff was said to be
on the outs with Jared and Ivanka but
now I don't know what mabini's
relationship is he's very smart guy and
he's got alike and also they're headed
into budget season so it's a good time
to have the presidents here okay is